if we could travel all our life without
the any worries of making living I think
that we most of us probably would travel
all day long this is uh it's a great
experience you meet new people all the
time new cultures
this is the this is the good part of
life the best part of life Welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
[Music]
Omer gozi welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for being with me how are you
hi Micah and thank you for having me
thank you very very much for for joining
me today omel you're the co-founder and
CEO of trip plan uh for the last five
years previously at ITC and uh and did a
bunch of different organizations and so
I'd love to to dive in with you over
these 20 minutes about your own journey
and that of travel Tech and what's
happening in travel and what trip plan
is all about what led to the founding of
trip plan with the problem that you're
solving and and the product itself so
we're gonna have a great time in these
20 minutes so let's you know kick things
off and tell me a little bit about
yourself
so for me travel is a passion it was
always a passion
and I used to organize trips I I think
since uh very early
from the days in the scouts later on
during the Army and I studied geography
the Hebrew and later I became a travel
guide
in Europe and in the United States so
for me it was a naturally a way and then
when I moved I relocate to Europe
I actually became a tourist 24 7. and
you know when you live abroad you are
the you become the address for your
friends and family
and every time someone is planning to
come and visit the first thing they ask
you is where to go and what to do they
don't ask you you know which flight to
take or where which hotel to book
what's interesting is where you go what
to look where to go and what to do and
this is how things left you know one
thing led to to another
incredible okay so tell me a little bit
about your time with Shimon Peres that's
something that's uh I think is a you
know remarkable and it's something that
I'm very jealous of and so I'd love to
just hear a little bit about that and
then we'll make our way back to tripland
and talk about the company that you
founded
so it was a amazing period for me as
well and I joined the shiman Paris when
he was the minister for regional
cooperation
in the in this office my
responsibilities were among many other
fields of
activities the high tech
and also a industrial zones
and agriculture
and through the activities in this
office was it was a ministerial office
we promoted The Joint programs and
projects with our neighboring countries
it was a fascinating time
it didn't last for too long
as you know but it was very interesting
very interesting I and I learned a lot
from him
what was the personal experience like
with him and you know did you have some
you know any interactions with him what
was it like for you
yes of course
um first of all when you work with a
person like in one person you feel you
touch history every time you you meet
you talk to him you meet with him you
feel like you touch part of the history
I mean this person is is a symbol
um I think that from the meetings and
the working visits and that we had that
we need together
um I learned a lot from him on a how to
look at things from different angles to
try to find the positive
element in every situation and also to
see how you can reach from maybe
difficult situation to a solution and I
think those are tools that I'm taking
with me I took with me
this journey of of tripland as well
I love it okay so so let's dive into
trip plan and you mentioned that you
were a travel guide yourself what what
was that about
I used to be a travel guy the
in countries like Italy east of Europe
in the United States I used to take
groups and it was look if if we could
travel all our life without the any
worries of make a living I think that we
most of us probably would travel all day
long this is a it's a great experience
you meet new people all the time new
cultures
this is uh this is the good part of life
the best part of life
I completely agree and and so and so
being in love with travel you know
that's a lot of people around the world
what is how did you know things come
about to create a tech company called
trip plan around this passion for travel
so as I as I mentioned before when I
leave the in Europe
I lived in Europe for a couple of years
uh it was the time that the mobile phone
became more and more popular
and I remember that I used to see those
tourists walking with the heavy books
the tour guides and I said to myself
this has to be changed I mean we have a
great
you know facility uh this mobile phone
has a great
advantages and this has to come together
this was many years ago but it was the
seat this is the start of everything
and for many years I thought how can I
actually combine the two things
and you know a I had the passion uh it's
very it's very challenging
and there is a self-fulfillment a part
in coping with the challenges and when
the technology came into the picture
uh this was the I think they
the aha moment that you say with this
with technology you can actually create
something which is generic and can help
many many people I I had the knowledge I
I had the experience of developing and
building itineraries I did it for many
people
um and with technology we actually can
you know Bring It Forward and make a
many people's life
very easy when it comes to a problem you
know this is where to go and what do
today is the number one pain
many people don't know how to do it
those who do know how to do it not
necessarily have the time or the patient
and they're going abroad and they don't
maximize their experience and it's a
pity yeah wow okay so so with the trip
plan you envision this One-Stop shop
where people you know you basically help
them organize and plan their trip tell
me a little bit about how your you know
you're thinking about this product in
the early days so five take me five
years back what is your plan or your
vision for what your plan is supposed to
do to people traveling or or may or
planning their travel needs
so I think that tripling is the next
level it's not a it's not a platform
that help you to plan your trip it's
actually planet for you yep and I
couldn't do it without my co-parter and
the co-founder Avi was mad with an
engineer algorithm engineer and I think
that the the big difference between what
we are trying to do and many other
attempts that were before us or even
parallel to us is that we are actually
bring together two different aspects
combining the tourism knowledge
expertise with a very strong a
technology experience
and when you combine those two things
together
you actually
this is what makes tripland what it is
tripling uh asks you to provide very few
pieces of information like when you're
traveling where you where you travel
when uh with whom and what's your field
of Interest
and based on this information we
actually take what the destination has
to offer and try to take the best part
of the out of this list
and connect it to your character as a
traveler because you know if you go to
let's say Paris With Friends you
probably will travel differently when
you go to Paris with your family
it's actually same destination but
totally two different trips and it's our
job to try and connect your characters
and needs to what the destination has to
offer
and so so if we're looking now at this
trip planning idea it sounds a little
bit complicated I mean if people have a
difficult time doing it themselves then
obviously with technology can help but
it requires
um you know an interesting approach so
how do you use technology to plan
people's trips and and I think that an
interesting segue after that is also
thinking about sort of the psychology of
the traveler of there's a lot of trust
that needs to come into place here so
I'd love to to also touch on that soon
but how or how are you from a product
perspective
you know approaching this trip building
aspect
so
I wouldn't go into the technology but it
is really tripping is a travel deck it's
a technology company first and foremost
uh there is a heavy technology
involving Ai and machine learning and
the the idea is to take a structured
data and make it a structured data
and this is the first obstacle to try
and take out of the enormous amount of
information to take the information that
is accurate and most relevant then once
you manage to filter out the point of
interest that fit the users characters
the next challenge is to try and take
those points and organize them on a map
in a way that you maximize your time you
don't want to send the tourist
from one side of the destination to
another site you want to organize the
the time in a way that you will maximize
his time and experiences
and this is all about this is what 3
print is all about and then so how are
you how do you create this relationship
with the traveler both getting to know
what they want and then
and then helping them you know actually
use the plan that you provided
so first of all we we know we use cloud
sourcing okay so we the solution that we
provide today is based on crowd sourcing
and we know that it's not necessarily
fit everyone right uh in the in the
future with more and more users we will
be able to uh serve more and more types
of Travelers but we know it we know it
to be aware of this
um and we're trying to improve ourselves
with every traveler and if you remember
a couple of years ago I went ways came
to the world
um
people were very suspicious yep why why
should we trust a machine to plan our
way
in the robot once you did and you saw
it's great
then you develop this trusted distrust
the same goes here once people give us
the chance
and it's also difficult because the
challenge of planning a your itinerary
in in destination is so painful that
people if you need to go you will try to
find any solution that can help you so
once people use our platform
uh the fifth the feedbacks are so good
and you know people tell the friends and
and those friends speak with other
friends and we see that we see the
cycles of of grow
every day we you mentioned that we we
are existing five years but the
four and a half years we we were a
bootstrap we were a very few people and
what was that what was the decision for
that by the way so the the the the
financial I guess aspect of of what sort
of as an entrepreneur what were the
decisions that you were making in
building out this company
uh in Israel where we are based uh the
field the travel Tech ecosystem is
hardly exist
it's very easy to and to raise funding
for a cyber fintech this kind of area of
activity travel deck is not so
um let's say popular so for us it was
one way and with with the time and with
the technology that we've developed
um we now we see that the investors and
even this is start to show interest so
it's I think it's there's a process of
learning and we hope that step by step
we will manage to bring more and more
players to this area because travel is a
huge industry it's a huge industry that
lacks technology
and Technology can do a major change
in in the experience of many people
yeah it was the reason this was the
reason uh but we see we
um you know we step up above the radar
uh in August
recently and we see the the numbers of
users the downloads uh grow every day
and it's really really
um
cause happiness I don't know how to what
word do you use but it's it's happiness
it's a pure happiness
and so tell me what walk me through the
product flow for somebody who's joining
who's entering the the product the
website how do they what is the flow of
experience for the user
so tripping is the is an app and and the
website uh the reason why we are both
um we started as a
app because we're also a navigator in
destination so once we develop for you a
a route for every day you can actually
travel with us and see where you are on
the map on the routes that we planned
for you okay so it's it's uh basically
it's very simple once you choose your
destination and we have today more than
150 destinations the top destinations
tourist destinations and I need to say
that we can add any destination in in a
day basically once we
choose the destination and the dates
I need to choose if I have an
accommodation I can insert the name of
the alternate or the address
uh who I'm coming with whether it's a
family with my partner friends how fast
we like to travel you know some people
like to take it easy some people like to
see everything
and then you need to choose today we
have five categories exciting museums
shopping parking Etc
um in the future we will add we will
develop more filters
adjusted to the
um
to the uniqueness of every destination
for example in life will take Tel Aviv
for for in the future we will add the
culinary which is starting to be a major
issue and in one click you get a
customized daily route for every day
and on top of that we have two layers
one layer is the tourism activities like
food tour Segway tour maybe you know hop
on up off
the all the entry tickets
and also restaurants but hey I need to
emphasize that
the information that we provide you is
only along the route that we plan for
you okay we are not the platform to
search for a restaurant in a destination
the other platform for that we only
provide the information along the Route
now you're traveling now you you want to
know what activities are around you
and what the food options do you have
around you this is what will provide
interesting and um so tying back to
to the sort of the beginning of the
conversation leading to the founding of
tripland and he also touched on this a
little bit yourself you know a big part
of the show was asking you know why do
you do what you do why do you wake up
every day and continue to be the CEO of
triplan it's a decision you make so why
why do you continue to choose it every
day
I like I told you it's a it's um
something is it it's a passion
um and if if you know that you you're
good in something and you have a good
um a partners because this this is a
this is a long trip it's not just me and
my co-founder Avi we are a team of 10
10 members 10 10 staff members we are
all friends great professionals
we decided to go on this trip together
um so and we feel that we actually
change
many in people's life we feel that we
actually can change the industry
we think that
um you know if in the past people used
to travel abroad and the main issue was
you know where you stay today is what
you do
and it's not so far the day that people
will choose the destination according
to the what the destination has to offer
and we we will be there with our
platform to provide those answers
I really want to thank you for taking
the time to be here and sit with me and
share with me the story of triplan from
its founding to some of the different
considerations to what you're doing
today and then most importantly the
Fulfillment that you get from from doing
this work so I really want to thank you
and wish you best of luck with trip plan
I'll continue cheering from the side and
thank you very much thank you very much
and if you go up traveling don't forget
download tripland
wonderful
[Music]